what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation we are here for cobra kai cf52 uh
you're gonna watch this right now ladies and
gentlemen uh we're joined with john how are you i
am fantastic andy gordon how are you i'm
doing well my friend thank you these shirts
are comfortable andrew got them for us i'll
mention in every video yeah subscribe and
click that notification bell get notified when
our reaction for the next episode of cobra kai
is up leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
super duper helps us out bull length reaction
watch as long as we sync up with your own copy
of cobra kai over for super sexy rejects at our
patreon page where we cover several shows the
same tier reaction highlights and watch alongs
included exclusively last of the team at prepper
thank you for listening down these highlights
if you're already binging with us you probably
skipped all that intro so let's watch this show
ah holy crap i didn't think we'd
be getting this here what's your
my i love that we're getting all this backstory
chosen has become one of my favorite characters
hey hey
you're gonna hit your own car man little guy
is a real harmful hectic did you ever think
of heaven anymore he's not mine he's from her
previous marriage never had any kid of my own
perfect even got married we
started talking about having kids
and then i did some terrible things you can
leave mexico without a few stories right
please i owe you let me show you a good time
this looks like the mexican version of the
larusso house i was just thinking that actually i
don't just fight for a trophy i want to be strong
to defend what's mine what about you might be
a sensei oh no that's it that is everything i
thought i had lost my honor um cricket do
reference no one can take honor from you
only you can take honor from yourself how's
it going here i like that sentimentality
where are you from exactly sensei kyoto
i've always loved the fushimi inari shrine
uh too many tourists nanzanji temple
much better for your next visit
let's have a japan off guy at the impound lot said
we need 4 000 pesos it's like a million dollars
it's a red sabina i think i'll burn a hole right
through you oh this camera this camera this camera
this is our shot to get back on track i'll do it
no rob i got us into this like you said this is
our best shot and i know i can win it's like
karate kid part two with daniel with the ice
i was thinking the deer hunter uno
moss give me the hottest pepper you got
he is nothing like what you said he was
you you were wrong about me he's smart
he's generous he's respected
he uh oh he's like a mob boss
he's about to learn the truth even the jar is hot
use that kata to eat the pepper
did he palm it
yeah yeah buddy disrespectful ruined all
that money disgusting way to win nichols
what's on your mind excited to
take things to the next level
what's the point you'll just
pay to make me champion again
wow it was an insurance policy you still won the
fight did i of course you did you're the champion
i know it but russo knows it the whole
valley knows it if you don't believe it
then you're the only person who doesn't oh my
god such a manipulator if you choose to leave
i won't hold it against you but if you come back
tomorrow i will make you the future of this dojo
you snake he's such a master manipulator i love it
what were you chewing on then nice that
was very clever this is acceptable cheating
i made a lot of money back in the day but
not in the restaurant business the kind
of business where you make a lot of friends in
high places enemies too but i put the password
step back from that ledge my friend this plan
has an expiration date silver's too smart
eventually he'll figure us out and when he does
be ready to fight yamazaki such a faster
rhythm to this season i lost a fight
a fight i should have won rivalries die slow
deaths i have a rival in this dojo business
in fact scotland russo there's some michael
keating quality about it hector the salazar
passover
look at the back of the shirts
still they say fbi in the front
who were you on the phone with earlier
just my mom she's checking up on her not
all right right right right now are you
with the fats no no no absolutely not
hey give me your phone i got
nothing i'm going to mail me oh
make me ask again holy [__] she just
turned really scary i know he's good
he's gonna see a picture of carmen isn't
he i'm gonna look through your entire phone
sorry
people are not always what they seem
you can never be too short take
it from me such an ironic line
mexico has an experienced eagle thing
johnny
elbow to the nose
i'm with the female body inspector i
figured you'd appreciate that very much
this one dude terry's so good
he's so suspicious of him
he'll get that rich without
being suspicious a toast then two
riding the wrongs of the past
and coming back on top katie
oh man that's scary all that money i'm
gonna lay low a few days maybe a week or two
grandma yeah and then louise totally fine
she's only after my money in the first place
that's a big shot this dude
is drinking all the time
that woman i told you about she couldn't stun
me doing my business and her mother even worse
and you know what i regret
nothing wow i should probably get going actually
you should at least tell them
what for they get so complicated
i would never make a phone call
in this guy's eye line i know
or talk to anybody hey mom oh you were
right please tell me you're okay mickey
miguel
his real father showed up
give robbie a hug too what an
interesting note and that's you know
where's everyone else no class today
there's some business i need to take care of
oh what a shot arrangement am i hurting
on the contrary right on time falling
i take out all the senseis yeah he
knows the truth every time i raise
a class with one of my old friends from
kyoto we toast come by with my new friend
kyoto yeah race is a glass some glorious
bastard [__] only say in okinawa yeah
you bastard anyone who takes this man down gets
the job and i will pay triple what i promised
if chosen wins does he get the job yeah yeah
it's the sorry six times are it man soon
oh damn you have to mess these boys up
the sigh
nice
that guy knew
texting me just not doing anything
daddy
oh jesus
yeah
and i take the job
homeboy likes a challenge hey so hard right
now he's going to call him mike barnes
let's get him back oh man
buddy buddy all right john andrew went first last
time take it away we're gonna watch it in just a
minute so john go i am loving the season so far
i i you commented that it is moving kind of at a
breakneck speed i was a little taken aback that
we may be wrapping up the mexico story at least
in mexico for right now but i i i loved the whole
journey for miguel uh i thought the stuff with
robbie and johnny was really fun and everything
with chosen and terry i thought was really nicely
rendered because it's tense and it's like a chess
game back and forth and they constantly have you
wondering okay how much does this dude know when
is the shoe gonna drop because everything that
chosen and danny are doing right now is is assured
but a little too confident so you know there's a
shoe ready to drop and i thought the way they they
orchestrated that mind game was really nice like
you said in glorious bastards hell yeah yeah i
agree with everything you said i think uh one
thing that i really enjoyed in this episode before
i get to the easter eggs uh was tori and chosen
they have very interesting past um and the way
they relate to each other was really interesting
about you know cowardness and cheating and
finding the easy way and i really appreciated
those moments together and i'm really looking
forward i mean obviously we know chosen's not
going to be working with cobra guys so you
know they're not going to be having too many
more scenes of training together but just again
those scenes we did get i really appreciate it and
they held a lot of weight for me uh which i wasn't
expecting but uh i was kind of kind of taken aback
too like you said uh with the the breakneck speed
of this episode i was kind of uh you know really
curious that they went the decision to have terry
figure out that chosen so quickly uh was working
with daniel that was an interesting decision i'm
curious to see how it pays off through the rest
of the season but uh i love those two together
because they have such a complicated history with
at least with daniel larussa so seeing those two
interacting with each other and just laying it
out and again just the chess game that they
were playing it just it made for such good
storytelling and such good interactions with
each other i really love those moments and
robbie and johnny they're really good together
as well i love that storyline and then as we
pointed out in episode one we knew that the there
were some ulterior uh you know i don't know if we
would say uh motives but at least from a character
perspective we knew that the dad wasn't miguel's
biological father was not who he seemed to be and
we knew that was going to happen so that dude that
actors really got ranged because he seems like
such a sweet mundane nice gentleman in the first
episode and then in like a really quick second
he turned into a really scary guy there when he's
like let me see your phone and all that so actor's
really good uh but a couple quick uh easter eggs
and references because i know you guys are all
dying for them uh the ones that i the ones that
i noticed uh when they're doing the betting and
uh johnny betts all in on uh robbie uh that was
very similar to karate kid part two and uh daniel
has to do the ice uh thing uh again sato betsan
chose or bets against daniel and mr miyagi bets
on daniel very similar to that i believe when uh
uh chosen as being called a coward by sato i
believe he calls mr miyagi a coward in part two
if i'm wrong please let me know in the comments
section and you should know i should know i know
my bad guys i believe so and then uh where he says
he had uh you know he's talking about with tori
with no honor and all that that's obviously how
we felt at the end of karate kid part two which
we saw in the references i could be totally off
on this one but when johnny is fighting the mma
guy and then throws the pepper or puts the pepper
in his eyes to help him defeat him it really felt
similar to me at least to the ending of three
ninjas that was made in 1992 uh where the grandpa
is about to lose to the bad guy snyder in the
film and he puts jelly beans in his mouth and that
helps him defeat him in the end so uh very similar
to that i don't know i'm throwing spitballing
i mean it's kind of just the motif yeah there you
go and then one other thing i did for him i did
forget to mention in the first episode but we saw
a little bit of again miguel's little well i guess
that wasn't his biological brother but uh the the
little boy that uh miguel's biological father the
son of yes exactly uh he's playing he's kicking
with the soccer ball very similar to uh karate kid
part one where daniel is kicking the soccer ball
on his knee and showing ali how to do it yeah dude
it's all connected it's all connected all
definitely easter eggs is miguel's alley yes yeah
uh i think what they're doing so i mean when
i said that the speed that it's moving at
i actually like the speed because there's such
a there's such a great rhythm to it that keeps
sort of this uh suspense alive throughout
like you know you're you're on a train going
somewhere and again because i've been viewing
this through the lens of a season four part two
it's not feeling rushed to me i'm like no this
is good we're just getting we're just getting
this train going let's go let's go you know it's
like leading somewhere because yeah they're doing
a lot of that sort of editing choices of having
characters talk and then overlapping into a scene
that's happening later on so like a present so you
have one part where daniel and chosen are talking
now it's already moving on to the next scene and
their dialogue from that scene is overlapping so
we can keep the flow going and so i like i like
the speed of it actually i really did enjoy it
i think the stuff with miguel and his dad was
pretty powerful i think that actor whoever plays
the dad like you were talking about was excellent
like the he because he seems like he does have
just so much turmoil from his past like that whole
speech when he's lamenting about having no regrets
you can tell he's like bullshitting himself that
there is just so much pain and sorrow in this guy
but he chooses a very specific path to go down
like he has chosen to leave behind the loved ones
so there is no point in miguel trying to confide
to this guy like hey i actually am your son
there is no true purpose to it i like how this
show carries on those themes of familial bonds
and understanding the difference between blood
connection and then who we choose to define as
our family as well like it was so tender i forgot
all about johnny and robbie um but when they did
show up i was so in the in the moment of what was
happening and i i thought i've never learned how
to say his name properly uh does anyone know how
to say his name properly the actor plays miguel
oh i could attempt to spell it better than
i know how to say it show low there you go
i think miguel i think his performance is just
excellent like i i love what he's doing here
so much more than what i i want to say
he's been slighted in the last couple of
seasons he's always been great but like i
remember the first season he was such like
one of the focuses yeah he was such a central
figure and then it's kind of bringing it back
to that and i think he's excellent and he and
this is the kind of shoe really yeah would watch
his blue beetle movie like look how good of an
actor this guy is he's amazing and of course like
the fight scenes with johnny and robbie kind of
having a buddy comedy situation of father and son
and getting into these these adventures with each
other and they're like beating up people in mexico
it's funny [__] it's funny [__] and yeah the
stuff the scenes were chosen and terry uh sizing
each other up and trying to figure each other out
like you just know i've never i've never noticed
but there's like a michael keating quality to tear
to the actor who who's taylor silver thomas ian
griffith one day you'll remember that there's a
very very michael keating quality to the way the
man talks at times they got the same mouth they do
there's a similar mouth and delivery at times and
there's like there's there is that uh does that
be devious devious quality about the way they
talk and i love it basically what greg's saying
if they ever reboot beetlejuice this is their guy
this is their guy right here don't use the actual
michael keaton use thomas ian griffin griffith
yeah whatever thomasi and griffith thomas ian
church uh yeah used thomas ian griffith for it
so yeah i mean there's still because there's so
many story lines right now that they do have to
kind of balance it out with what you can focus on
like we didn't really get much daniel this time
around um no samantha we haven't really checked
in with many of the students from miyagi though
no they were kind of just like background players
in the last episode and they're nowhere here
they just showed up yeah they're barely there's
so much that they have to flesh out and it's
it's keeping it very right now it's just like
really just so focused on the main characters and
i'm like i'm liking what they're doing so far and
uh it does feel different like it's i like that ad
i just love that tone that this show has that that
suspenseful cheese is the best way i can describe
it like it's always like a little cheesy but still
like just gripping where i'm not laughing at the
show for what it's doing it's just the right
pitch where it's having fun but it's also like
intense and cares a lot about its characters it's
really great i really love this show yeah and they
find ways of mixing and fight like i feel like in
season two or three maybe there was like a peak of
like man there are just fights all the time this
is getting like a little too high concept almost
for the world that it's in and i feel like they've
balanced the the appropriate amount of cheese
to motivate the fights where it's like they're fun
and bouncy but they're also kind of cool you know
well it's all about balance yeah that's right i
mean the the fights are perfect for the cobra kai
karate kid world yeah yeah like there is a lot of
like attack one at a time people waiting for a hit
to happen someone back there not doing anything
you know there's actually there's a little fight
it's the way it but it works for the world yeah
it is you know if i was watching like a john wick
movie i would be like what's going on here if
you're watching donnie yen you'd be like what's
that yeah but for the karate kid world i'm like
nah it's perfect this is this this is the fighting
style of the 80s right now i want to add one last
thing that scene we got with miguel where he's
crying on the phone to his mother and then johnny
shows up it really felt like a very nice payoff to
that very emotionally weighted scene that we got
uh towards the end of season four after the prom
where miguel came to johnny's uh how our apartment
and johnny and he called him robbie it was it just
felt like a nice payoff to that scene but in
a better way for miguel yeah it's true it's
very true i think this time they're finally
gonna get along they're probably gonna have
to like fight it out or something they'll fight
and then they'll become brothers yeah i think
this is the because last time last season was
about johnny and daniel coming together and now
it's i think it's going to be about robbie and
miguel coming together and then sam and tory
double dating oh what if it ends on a double date
oh man that would be nice that'd be really lovely
interesting but lovely more to come more to
come guys uh what'd you guys think of this
episode leave your thoughts down below keep a
lookout for episode three we're gonna watch in
just a couple minutes so subscribe click that bell
leave a like before we go to this with the patreon
brendan benzie brendan we're gonna look at
what your name means in urban dictionary today
drum roll please because you know what looking
up the actual name meanings what's the point
here we go brandon is the friend you want to keep
because he will put others before himself he cares
about everyone especially to the people he knows
best it's true we have a friend named brandon
and uh he is like that so i would just assume
so you're like that you're the exact same way
my fiance dater to brandon i hate that guy brandon
can make girls laugh and make them feel like the
only girl in the world good for you man you
know our the brandon we know can do that too
and uh so did fiance's ex when he makes jokes
it's usually to make people feel happy he made
my fiance very very happy sounds like he was
a great guy everything i've heard when he does
things with but that means you do that when he
does things with his friends it usually ends with
trouble oh brandon you're crazy guy crazy crazy
guy brandon role so it was my fiancee zacks
he was just always uh he's always getting into
trouble belongs in prison brandon is the person to
keep secrets because he wants to make sure they
can let out anything that they wanted to say
it's good that we can trust you and i have told
my fiancee zach so many of my darkest secrets
i went there to hit him and then it did not it
went completely opposite i was opening my soul
he made you feel like the only girl in the world
brandon sometimes can be a dick but deep inside
he is a loving person he will get a fight with
someone if he has to it's good you can protect
us at our patreon page you can protect us and
he um of course you know my fiance sex he uh
he he's he's he's he's so full of dick he fights
a lot of you uh brandon honestly is someone you
need in your life because he'll do whatever he
has to do to make you feel happy he would make
a wonderful boyfriend because he will care about
you and protect you with his life dude like a good
safety jacket i'm leaving my fiancee so she
can get back with brandon it's for the best
friend thank you so much for
being here buddy and it looks
usually around a dictionary means something
mean or perverted you've got a sweet treat
you've got a great urban dictionary thanks
for being part of our patreon page buddy
you